[Music]
and tomorrow
trust me Kelly Ripa is finally
announcing a permanent live co-host
since Michael Strahan a shocking
departure in May 2016 Kelly has had more
than 60 guest co-hosts on the show my
co-host today is our real person a real
bore she's amazing Richard Curtis is the
high school teacher who beat out
thousands in a contest for a chance to
co-host he was such a hit they brought
him back a few weeks later but a source
close to Curtis tells et this is
unlikely because quote they stopped
calling him Fred Savage is another fan
favorite et chatted with him after his
third time co-hosting next to Kelly and
asked if he would accept an offer I
coming in town with my family they're
meeting me here or taking a vacation in
New York so the timing worked out and
whatever they call I love to come to it
it's always a lot of fun kids start
school I in the fall so that's that's
the priority right now you pee in the
pool by any chance do I pee in a pool I
have like a very no you can be honest I
don't want to know I never be in the
book one who definitely seems to be a
fan favorite Jerry O'Connell who always
brings the laughs Kelley made it clear
Anderson Cooper was her top choice at
one point but Anderson took himself out
of the running when he renewed his
contract with CNN would you take the job
if offered look I'm very happy at CNN I
you know it would be a dream to work
with Kelly but nobody's offering him
anything so you can do it all sweetie
Chris Hardwick is extremely busy with
his own gigs but has said he would
seriously consider taking the coveted
chair next to Kelly I love doing it I
guess I would have to see if they asked
me and if I you know I I don't think I
would stop doing anything that I'm
currently doing but you know if I could
do everything I would say I would really
destroy the Christian model I like it
Morris Chestnut has co-hosted several
times but indicated he would probably
not take the job I'm sure it's a great
job as a highly coveted job right now
I'm doing a TV show rosewood but
Christian Slater is another frequent
guest who would definitely hop on board
if asked I live about you know six
blocks away from there it's right there
in the city
it's it's one of the greatest jobs ever
I love her she's amazing so yeah
Kelly who is your top pick for Kelly's
co-host let us know in the comments
below
[Music]
you